advocate for women that go through these
situations
I don't know what the stats tell you I
don't know what the stats are not
telling you because these things you
cannot actually regulate because a lot
of things go it's from um can I just
just to give you perspective it's from
people that work with these couples and
that work at women's shelters will tell
you this so much so much so much so that
they're like there is um the three
feminists that came up with the the
system that the justice and I'm
butchering this but it's like the system
that the justice system is built on that
automatically assumes the woman's the
victim they were saying that even in
their practice it wasn't what they saw
that they were saying you know what it's
actually mutually abusive